[موسيقى]
كان علينا توجه الى وزاره الموارد المائيه
العراقيه لنقابل هناك المتحدث الرسمي باسم
الوزاره علي راضي لنساله عن تركيا وايران
اللذين يقومان بانشاء سدود وتغير مجرى
الانهار ما صار يشكل خطرا قد يساهموا في
اختفاء انهار كبيره مثل دجله والفرات
[موسيقى]
اليوم اداره نتحدث عن موضوع الصحه المائيه
واسباب
متعدده منها تاخذ الجانب الفني واخرى تاخذ
الجانب الطبيعي على سبيل المثال والفرات
اليوم التوسع الكبير لتركيا بانشاء السدود
الخزنيه وتوسع بالمشاريع الاروائيه اثرت
بشكل كبير جدا حقيقه بالتحكم والسيطره على
المياه همم وارادات العراق المائيه اضافه
الى موضوع النمو السكان الكبير ايضا اللي
حصل على طول النهار وخصوصا في دول المنبع
هذا الجزء احنا عاده مع همم يعني نصنفه
ضمن الامور الفنيه اما الامور الطبيعيه
الاخرى فهي طبيعه السنين المائيه متغيره
احنا كنا نتذكر في عام 2019 العراق
الاستفاده وزاره الموارد ما كان الهجهود
المتميز بالاستفاده من كل الايرادات
وزياده الخزينه الماهر في عموم السدود
والخزانات
للمنظومه الخزنيه من العراق وبالنتيجه
خدمتنا بشكل كبير للمواسم اللي ثلاثتها
واللي علينا بها من ظروف شحامائيه وسنين
صحيحه نسمع كثيرا بجانب التركي اتهم او
يدعي ان العراق
لا يدير موارده المائيه بشكل جيد همم
ناسيا الوضع بانه 80% من الحصه المائيه
تاتي من الجانب التركي
ببعض النظريه نسميه بالاسترومان فيوري انه
همم يعني يعمل السجود 22 همم هايدروجين
ويتهم الجانب المقابل بانه لا يمتلك خطه
اداره لاداره المياه طبعا كذلك ايضا من
الجانب الايراني اكثر من سبعه روافد
اساسيه حور مساره حول الحوض يعني حوض
الايراني دون المرور بالعراق فهذا
المفاوضات تعتمد على جيبلتكس يعني اساس
المفاوضات هذه السدود وقطع المياه هو
اساسا اعتماده على جانب سياسي انه العراق
وبلد منتج للنفط وهذا واضح كامل لعام 1993
المفاوضات العراقيه التركيه كان ما احد ما
يعرفها بشكل واضح للايام سبب انتشار
السوشيال ميديا همم كانت مطالب الاتراك
انه همم مياه مقابل النفط وكانت مزاعم
واضح من البدايه فانشاء هذه السجود لها
تاثير ايضا سياسي على ان العراقي يجب ان
يفاوض على المياه للحصول على مصادر الطاقه
وهي الكثير من ابار النفط في جنوب العراق